- [Interviewer] Sorry about that.
All right, Brad.
Brad, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- Michigan, Detroit area.
- Detroit?
- Suburbs.
- [Interviewer] And how was your family?
You grew up with both your parents?
- Yeah.
It was a great family,
I had a great childhood.
- [Interviewer] That's nice to hear.
And after you left life
at home with your parents,
where did you go from there?
- I started traveling around.
Different places.
Colorado, Boston,
Louisiana, and then I ended up in Florida,
and what was happening was,
I was drinking too much,
and I was an alcoholic, really.
But I found AA, and I got sober.
But I didn't stay sober.
It lasted for about a year and a half.
And then, I relapsed,
and I've been relapsing
ever since, basically.
So I have good periods, but
then I have bad periods.
- [Interviewer] Are you
using any of the drugs
that are out here in the street?
- Yeah, drugs are part of my story.
Yep.
- [Interviewer] They're all
the same problem, basically.
Alcohol or--
- I think so, yeah.
- Drugs.
- Yeah, sure are.
- [Interviewer] Just different
forms of the same problem.
I believe so.
Alcohol can be the worst drug.
- [Interviewer] It's so easy.
- It can really tear you up.
I mean, look at 'em.
- [Interviewer] So what age were you
when you started with drinking?
- When I knew I was an
alcoholic was when I was 35.
- 35?
- Yeah.
In Florida.
And I got sober, like I said.
For a year and a half,
everything was great.
But then I drank.
Then I got sober again, and then I drank.
And it's been like that ever since.
And I'm 64 now.
- [Interviewer] You're 64?
- Yeah.
I was 55--
- How long you been
down here on Skid Row?
- About seven years.
I don't remember exactly.
I have one of those SROs.
It still counts as homeless
when they do the census,
but I've had one for about three years.
But I was on the streets
for three years, too.
- [Interviewer] And what is your drug now?
- A mixture of meth and crack.
I try to stay away from the
crack, it's too expensive.
I don't really like crack.
So, if I do meth, I don't do crack.
It's a lot cheaper.
- I've heard that story a lot.
- Yeah, that's why--
- Meth seems to be a--
- Substitute.
- A way out of
crack addiction.
- Yeah, and it's a way,
crack was a way out of drinking.
And now, meth is a way out of crack.
- [Interviewer] What do you
think the core problem is?
'Cause drinking, meth,
crack, kind of symptoms of
something deeper--
- I have an addictive
personality, I think I'm
an alcoholic, basically.
- [Interviewer] But do
you believe that the,
the drive to numb some
painful event in your past
is what's been--
- It's not that.
Alcohol is a tricky thing.
I'm not trying to numb
some pain, I don't think.
Maybe I have--
- 'Cause your childhood
seems pretty good.
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Your
childhood seemed pretty good.
- Yeah, it was wonderful.
I just have that addictive personality.
The dependence on something.
I think it's, not everybody has it.
Some people do.
There's a small percentage
of people who do.
And you either got it, or you don't.
It's like a disease.
- Yeah.
- Mental, physical, and spiritual.
I think that's what my problem is.
I know that's what it is.
I've never been able
to stay sober, though.
For longer than a,
the first time I got sober
was like, a year and a half,
was the longest that was.
And after a year and a half,
everything was beautiful.
Birds were chirping, and I was
happy, the sun was shining.
And I felt great all the time.
And I drank, and, (sighing)
I was drinking like, 18 beers a day.
And I bought 24 beers every day.
And going to work, I tore myself up.
And then, I lost my job,
not related to drinking.
And
I met a girl, real pretty
girl, I fell in love with her.
And she smoked crack, and
I smoked, then I started,
and that was, it was it.
And then, I smoked crack for a while,
and then it was meth, 'cause I wanted,
I don't even like crack anymore.
Just overdoing it.
And that's it.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have kids of your own?
- [Brad] No.
- [Interviewer] No kids?
Never married?
- [Brad] No.
- [Interviewer] And where do you see,
what do you see for your future?
If addiction is gonna
be a nagging problem.
- [Brad] It's not really a problem.
I'm 64, so I'm retired.
I don't get much money
a month, but I get it.
Next year, I'll be able to get Medicaid
or Medicare, whatever it is.
Medicaid, yeah.
And Section 8 housing.
And that's it, I don't have a future.
That's my future, really.
I enjoy life.
- [Interviewer] You're happy?
- [Brad] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you have friends?
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What was the
lowest point in your life?
- Lowest?
- Yeah.
- Oh, I have many low points, many.
I think it was, I was in Alabama
once, that was pretty low.
I was hitchhiking around the country.
And I was pretty young,
I was in my 20s still.
I would ride in freight trains.
You know, you hop a train and you go.
And I was just doing it for fun.
I wasn't doing it to get anywhere.
Just something to do.
But then, I got messed up in
it and I couldn't get out.
It's like I was trapped.
And it got pretty bad.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
addiction's a curse, isn't it?
- [Brad] Yeah, it sure is.
Sure is.
- [Interviewer] All right.
Well, thank you so much for talking to me
and sharing your story.
- All right.
- [Interviewer] I appreciate it.
Good luck with everything.
- Thank you.